in this course Anya Kubo will teach you
how to build three internal applications
that are useful for many types of
businesses the applications focus on the
needs of employees managers and
developers Anya is great at breaking
things down and makes it simple to
follow along when learning new Concepts
hello everyone here on free cooker
camper can build three apps and three
hours using postgres Stripes API as well
as an emailing integration my name is
Anu Kubo software developer as well as
course creator online and together we
are going to build three internal tool
applications that one business might use
we will build an application used by
employees an application used by
managers and an application used by
developers all linked to one database so
just like you might see when working for
a real small to medium-sized company now
hold on yeah this seems super
overwhelming why
don't worry I'll be taking you through
everything step by step starting with an
explainer and ending with three separate
tutorials leaving you with the
confidence to build your own internal
tools as well as some new business logic
so by the end of this course you will
have these wonderful applications to run
an e-commerce store from the back end or
back office side
this is essentially what the operations
team at a company will see
the application will display all items
in our inventory that we can sell and we
will be getting this data from a
database that we will build using
postgres the data will be for mobile
phones with each item having a price
image URL description and unique SQ or
identifier a data management purposes
the application will also allow us to
manage the purchases made by customers
this means we will be able to search for
orders and create refunds the refunds
will be done thanks to a strike API
integration
on top of that we will also be able to
email customers with auto-generated
texts and this is some custom JavaScript
that we write as well as the SMTP API
you will also be able to see all other
employees in the company thanks to this
tab right here next up we will build the
managers app in terms of admins of the
company
so imagine that you're a manager and you
need to view all the employees at your
company as well as their private
information
you might also need to delete someone
from the database or edit their details
such as their title or address for
example well you can do that here as
well as view the end injury too to
delete items from the inventory and add
new items to the inventory
another nice feature we are going to add
is the ability to see analytics of which
employee is gaining the most revenue for
your company
and finally we will build a b2d app or
business to developer application
this app will offer additional developer
friendly functionality
what this means is that the app will be
able to facilitate orders made through
API course by displaying the endpoints
right here as well as a bunch of other
stuff
okay so a lot to get through I'm excited
let's do it this course is made possible
by a grant from ritual the local
platform built for Developers
retool has drag and drop tools and
Integrations to help developers build
front ends for their internal apps right
on top of apis and data sources
in this course we'll be using resource
free plan which is available for teams
up to five people
[Music]
okay so let's do it I've started off on
the retail platform which is the
platform I'm going to use in order to
build these internal apps and I'm just
going to go ahead and create new from
App okay so let's go ahead and call that
up something I'm gonna go ahead and call
it Mobby as that is my fake company's
name it's a mobile company we're going
to be making a mobile company's internal
apps and this is going to be the
employee app so just go ahead and do
that you can of course Call It Whatever
You Wish
and there we go as you can see this is
just some default settings we have a
table in here and we also have a query
that has been set up for us in order to
get going however I am going to delete
this so we can start with a clean slate
so just go ahead and delete yours and
then I'm also going to delete this table
simply by clicking on it and then
pressing delete on your keyboards great
so now we have a clean slate we can
control which tabs we want to see up
here so here I can actually see the
state of my queries okay when I get them
and we can also control seeing the tab
down here or we can minimize it as well
as this tab on here which provides us
with all our inbuilt components
so
let's go ahead and undo this first off
I'm just going to create a container
that's going to hold our tables our
order tables our inventory table and our
employee table to show us the employee
all of that data so I'm just going to go
ahead and call this
order
management
dashboard
just like so I'm going to choose to
align it to the left like that and then
we can also choose a color for this
container's header so to do that just
make sure you're on the actual container
itself
and then on the inspect tab we can
scroll down and we can give our header a
background color so I'm just going to go
ahead and select one of these I'm going
to go with primary and if we want to
change it we can just drag this just
like so to make it a little bit lighter
or darker that is totally up to us okay
if we go lighter the color will change a
bit but we can also overwrite the
default text color I'm just going to
keep it white as I think that looks good
great so we can change the header we can
change the footer if we want to add one
to this we can change the Border radius
the Border there's literally so so much
that we can do
so perhaps while I'm here I'm just going
to go ahead and change the Border radius
of this to have the Border color that is
the same okay
so let's just go with this
I'm just going to drag it to be
somewhere up here
great and then we can of course override
it to be exact as well
okay so that's our first container now
I'm going to use the tabbed component so
just this one right here and drag it in
and we're going to have different tabs
as I said the first one is going to be
to see all the orders so let's go ahead
and call this orders we can either give
an icon if we wish so I'm just going to
go ahead and just give it a little crown
because they are one orders so I think
that is kind of cute and then for view
two we're going to have the inventory so
that our employees can see the inventory
in our shop so inventory and again just
choose an item so I'm just going to go
ahead with
this one right here
that kind of makes sense for an
inventory and the third one I'm gonna
have is for employees so the employees
can also see other employees that work
here and here I'm just gonna find one of
a person so just like so
great so if I click on any of these it
should open a different tab but of
course we need to put the content of
that tab in here so I know that the
first one is going to be a table so
let's go ahead and drag that in and this
is the default information that is being
fed to our table we're going to delete
all of this and actually feed in our
data from a database so just go ahead
and delete that to see we can start
fresh
with the inventory so if you click on
here I'm going to show all the products
in our company however I'm going to
choose to Showcase another component for
you and that is list view which will
show us all the items as a list
so let's go ahead and search for list
view so I'm just going to drag that in
here like so
and this is cool because we can now drag
other components into here so for
example if I drag an image then we'll
have loads of different images this is
kind of the equivalent of mapping in
JavaScript okay so let's have an image
I'm also going to have let's put some
text for example so we can put some text
here this could be a title and then we
can also have some text for a
description if we wish as well there's
maybe some other text for you know the
price of the item as well as how much we
have the product so let's go out and put
that here so I've done that just so you
could see how this is being mapped out
to all the other list items and our list
items so let's go ahead and select the
list view component are actually just
hard coded to number three but we can of
course change this dynamically too once
we get our data feeding in
so we'll come back to this perhaps let's
also I'm just going to change this for
now we can use HTML elements in here if
we want so I can use the h2 tag and this
could be the product name
for example so that is just an example
of something we can do or we can make it
smaller if we want so if we choose an H3
tag that'll just be that tiny bit
smaller too here we're going to have the
price so we can make it
bold simply by using these two stars
like so so I can just put USD and just
hard code this as zero to start with but
we know that the price is going to go in
here okay and if we don't want to do it
this way we can also just put an H
five this time perhaps let's see what H5
looks like Okay so let's use an H5
element for that and here we're just
going to again I'm just going to use an
H5 element for this just to keep it
consistent on both sides visually and
let's go ahead and put the product ID
as well as
the stock level
so that is something that we will have
here and I'm just gonna make that a
little bit
longer for us so just like that and of
course this is going to be a description
of the product so I'm just going to put
this is a description
for now wonderful so this is just for us
to have an idea of what's going to go in
here what kind of data let's move on
the last thing we're going to do is
employees and once again for this one
I'm going to have a table so let's go
ahead and create and then find our table
component and just drag it in here at
the moment as I said it has default data
just hard coded into here so it's an
array of objects I'm just going to
delete that so you can feed our own data
in later on
great
now the next thing I want to do is say
that when we have our orders and when we
select a line from the orders we want to
actually view the order visually along
with the product pictures so I'm just
gonna for now drag in another container
so just like so and I'm going to get rid
of the title this time I don't want it
there and we can do so easily so if we
click on the container too
and we can do so easily by simply hiding
the Heather like sir okay great so at
the moment we're just using the default
names however we can change this so
perhaps let's go ahead and do that I'm
going to name this to management
container
and let's change this to
display
container
this tabbed container I'm just going to
put management
tab
container
okay so there we go and then I'm happy
with all these tabs one times two times
three that makes sense and table one
well this is going to be for the orders
so let's go ahead and maybe change that
order table
the inventory list
so this list view I'm gonna put invin
Tori list and the employees I'm going to
change this to to just make sure to
click on employees that's table two
let's read in table two to be employees
table just so that when people look at
our code that we will be writing later
it will be more readable and make more
sense okay so there we go we've renamed
all these components so feel free to do
that you of course don't have to I just
wanted to show you that it is possible
okay wonderful so in here when I click
on a line I essentially want to be able
to view the order number so let's go
ahead and delete this I'm going to use
an H
Four Element for this this time so let's
put the closing tag and I'm going to put
you are viewing order number
and then we're going to put the order
number in here okay so whatever it is
that will show up
perhaps let's make this a little bit
smaller while we're at it I'm going to
make this an H5 and
great now when we select an order I
essentially want the order to show up
right but what if an order has more than
one product so for this we're going to
have to get the list view again because
we're going to map that data on to the
list view so just go ahead and drop that
in here drop that in the container just
like so and in here maybe let's rename
this to something more readable I'm
going to go ahead and rename this to
order list
View
and in here I'm just going to drag in
the image of what the order is
so just like that I'm just going to make
it bigger and then I'm also going to
drop in some text because I want to
display what this actually is so I'm
going to make this an H
3 element this time
and I'm just going to show
the product name
and then I'm also going to just drop in
the description okay just so it's really
visible to the employee
this is
a description
cool and then we should probably also
have the product ID as well so let's go
ahead and drop that in here
so product ID and we're going to put
that
right there
wonderful
so I think this is looking good we can
space this out if we want
so I can put a divider if I wish just to
make it really obvious that you know the
next item has started
great
so this is what it looks like now we can
also actually hard code the height of
this display container so I would do so
by adding the height as being fixed and
now if I just go ahead and change the
height of this
great and now I could just scroll
through them with the height of this
component being fixed rather than being
Dynamic based on how many items we have
in the list view that expands the
components okay let's carry on
before we get going to creating the
refunds and notification section that I
want to have here I think let's start
with actually importing the data that we
can work with and to do this I've
actually gone ahead and created this
file for you so you can literally copy
it and drop it into your app okay so for
the purposes of this tutorial we are
going to be using a manage database on
retour however of course in a real life
situation you'd probably want to hook
this up to actual real database
I've gone ahead and written some code to
create a table for the customer so each
customer is going to be represented by a
customer ID or contact name title
address where they live and a way to
contact them I've also done one for the
employee which is kind of like the
customer however it has more information
as each employee at my company has
employee ID a fast name last name title
we also store that buff that you know
just for fun if we want to send them
some value notifications that higher
date as well as where they live and how
to contact them as well as their company
photo
next we have the product so all the
products in our inventory which we have
given an ID a product name a description
how much they cost and how many units of
these we have in stock as well as a
photo of the product
next we have the actual order so when a
customer makes an order we actually use
the employee ID that we assign to our
employee to find out which employee is
in charge of that order or took the
order the customer ID that we made
earlier to find out which customer made
this order and then we also have the
order date the required date by which
they need the order by the ship date the
ship address as well as the charge ID
that is going to come from stripe so
that we can make the refunds if we want
okay and lastly we just have the order
detail as this is the sales order but we
don't actually know how many items are
in the order or anything so here we have
the product ID the unit price and how
many of that product we got as well as
if there was a discount applied so this
is just of course sample data for this
tutorial please feel free to use it it's
nothing serious this is just for
tutorial purposes it's a fake database
that I have made okay so every order can
have as many order details as I want
next up we go about inserting data into
each of these tables so this is how you
would do it you would use the insert
into keyword you'd select the table you
then pick out all the columns
essentially that you want to insert data
into and then you do it by using the
values keyword and inserting the data in
the same order as the above okay so I
did this for the employees table the
products table the customer table the
sales order table as well as the order
detail table
now I won't be going into how to write
these SQL queries as this is not an SQL
tutorial okay if you want to check that
out there's plenty of resources on the
free codecam channel for you to have a
look at so please go right ahead okay so
all I'm going to ask you to do as I said
is just copy all of this like I'm doing
right now
to copy it and then back in here let's
get up the bottom Tab and I want you to
write a new resource query this time
it's going to be to the manage database
so go ahead and search for the manage
database you should have one in your
retour
and just go ahead and paste it all in
like so and hit save and run
okay so I'm just going to make this a
little bit bigger for you
and great you should see a pop-up that
says query one has ran successfully and
you will see the related tables in here
so those are all the tables in your
manage database I have a few more as
I've added some tables to a different
tutorial but as long as you have these
that should be fine that should have
worked so all your tables should be in
here along with all the columns that
essentially make them up okay so that's
quite useful for us let's just go ahead
and rename this to add data so it's very
easy for us to know which query is for
doing which thing
so great we've written our query to our
data and We've ran it so we've added it
to the manage database this is good now
that we've actually added our data we
need to retrieve that data we need to
get data and I want to do it by writing
another query so new resource query this
time I'm going to call this get let's
get the orders as that is the first
table that we created so get orders like
so or we can call it get sales orders to
be more precise as that is what our
table is called so there we go I've just
chosen to call it the same as the table
you don't have to but I've done it
because we're going to get that table so
make sure you're on the manage DB
resource and all I'm going to do is
write select
all
from so this is SQL sales order right
because that was what our table was
called so if I now save this and run it
you will see the table
show up right here so those are all our
orders
cool
so that is how you would get a table
from a database now to actually use this
I would select the table that I want to
populate with this data in this case
it's the order table and in here you're
going to use this a lot we're going to
get two Kylie braces so this is
something associated with retool these
two Kylie braces and we're gonna get
sales order data so we're simply getting
whatever the query is called which is
get sales orders and we're getting the
data associated with it and there we go
you've now populated this table with all
our orders
wonderful
another thing that's handy if you don't
know the structure of your data is to
use this Explorer Tab and look at the
state so as you will see here you will
see get sales orders and if I open this
up you'll see data which is an object
and then you'll see all the columns that
we can use as arrays cool
so I'm just going to minimize that again
now another cool thing that we can do
for this table yes of course we can
customize it so I can change the colors
if I wish so I can go ahead and make the
header background blue perhaps you know
to really match the vibe of this overall
component or what I can also do which is
probably more useful instead of using
the table names that come with our
database we can actually visually change
them to the user so we're not going to
be changing the database at all we're
just changing them visually to our users
okay so I can change this to order ID
so it doesn't have to be just all one
word so just like so and let's go ahead
and do the same for the customer ID so
customer ID
the employee ID employee ID so once
again we are not changing anything in
the database we're simply changing what
it looks like on this UI
it's also have the required date
D shift date
the shipped
dress
we can just have a dress really
region
postal code
country
and we don't really want the charge ID
to be visible so I can go ahead and hide
it like so that is an option for us too
so I've just gone ahead and hidden it
so now it won't be visible in our table
anymore if I scroll through okay it
finishes that country
great so this is looking good I'm just
going to go ahead and do the same thing
for the employees tables so this is a
bit of repetition for you what we did
before is create a new resource query
let's go ahead and call this get
employees
and then I'm going to select
all from the table employee so just like
so and hit save and run which will give
me back all my employees when this stops
running and then I'm simply going to
select the employees table and under
data I'm going to use the two curly
braces get the employees ID so whatever
we called our query and get the data
from it so here's a preview and here we
see that data wonderful
so once again we can choose to hide as
much as we want as this is the employee
tab I'm going to hide these sensitive
information as well as the photo so I'm
going to hide this I'm going to hide
where they live
so just like that as well as a dress and
the birthday but I am going to keep that
higher date a phone number for contact
as well as their first name and employee
ID
wonderful so that we go and of course we
can change these dynamically if we wish
to
so I'm also gonna while I'm here just
change this to be
employee
ID
last name
first name
a title so we have CEO vice president
sales manager that hired date
and of course that phone number
for contacting them if we need
great so this is looking wonderful
lastly I'm just going to do the
inventory so once again let's make a new
resource query I'm going to call this
get inventory
just like that and then we're going to
select
all from
you guessed it product this time
so we're going to get all the products
save and run
great so now I'm going to highlight the
list view this time so the inventory
list and the number of rows we're going
to change this dynamically so get up
your cardi braces use the get inventory
data and then I'm going to select
something that I want to pin my length
to I think that should be the product ID
as that is always going to be unique or
should be unique and I'm going to get
the length of this array
okay great so there we have it
as we've only got three items in our
inventory
that has been mapped out to three items
in my inventory list
okay
great
so now how do I feed data into this
imagery list well what I would do is
I would go ahead and select one of these
so here is the image and I would go
ahead and get the curly braces up again
use the query get inventory data get the
photo and we're going to Loop over each
photo in our array by putting in an i
okay so there we go we've looped over
everything in our array so there's our
three items and we're going to do the
same for the product name so just in
between the H3 tags that we added I'm
going to use the two Kylie braces I'm
going to use the get inventory data
query so they're getting into a query to
get the data and then I'm going to get
the product name and loop over
everything in my array
and the price as well so I'm just going
to go ahead and use the two Kylie braces
here you see the space between USD the
USD get inventory query to get the data
that comes back and I'm going to get the
unit price and once again open up an
array and use the I to Loop over
everything in our array
do the same for the description so two
curly braces get inventory query get the
data from it get the product description
open up our two brackets and pass
through an eye so we Loop over
everything
great and then finally for the product
ID well it's the same thing two curly
braces get inventory data then we get
the product ID and we Loop over by
passing through an i into an array and
finally get inventory data this time
it's the units in stock
and once again we pass through an eye
great
so this is looking really wonderful I'm
happy with this perhaps we can just move
this down a little bit so it's a bit
more centered
just like so as I think that might look
a little bit better for the next
products in line
wonderful
okay so this is looking good
let's move on so under orders what I
said is that if I select a row I
actually want to show the orders that
are associated with the order ID
so let's go ahead and do that next
so
what I'm going to do is just select this
title instead of having XX I'm going to
go into
this table which is called order table
so just type out order
table
like so and this time we're going to get
these selected row so just find selected
Row from the drop down select
did
row we're going to get the data order ID
okay so now whatever row we select this
will change as you can see it's changing
as I select a different right
wonderful and now using the same
approach we did for the inventory we're
going to Loop over all of these list
items in order to show all the products
associated with this order number so to
do this we're going to have to write
another query this time to get one
product so the resource query I'm going
to call get products so just one product
and the SQL I need to write for this
it's going to be select all from the
product table
where the product
i d
equals
any
and then we're going to pass through the
product ID that's associated with the
order and we know we can get that data
from the order detail table so let's go
ahead and write a query for that so
let's save this as it is this won't work
at the moment but let's make a new query
this is going to be called get sales
order
detail
I'm going to do select all
from
order detail
where
the order ID equals and I'm going to
enter this table called order table
I'm going to get this selected
row
data
order ID so just get the order ID
great so save this and run it so if we
select on this one right here you will
see that the order associated with it
has the product ID of three you'll see
its price we'll see how many of them are
ordered and we'll see the discount price
and if I select a different row you will
see that change and the order details of
this order will change okay so now we're
going to use this query in order to find
out what product IDs are associated with
which order ID and so to do this I'm
just going to use get sales order detail
data
product ID okay and just make sure that
this is in parenthesis and save and run
it
and great so that's all working well
we've now linked up the actual product
table to the sales order table
so now I can just click on here and go
into the get product query
so this one that we wrote right here to
get this photo URL so get product data
dot photo we're going to just Loop over
that by passing through and I just like
so
okay
great
so now let's go ahead and just try click
on any one of these rows
and you will see the order number here
changes as well as the picture as this
Samsung Galaxy is associated with this
order but you wouldn't know that from
looking at this line it's only thanks to
us getting the product and searching for
the product by the order ID that we're
able to get all of this extra
information
so now I can use this extra information
to finish this out so I'm going to go
into the get product query again and get
its data and this time get the product
name
as well as the description so get
product data
product description
as well as the product ID okay so I'm
just going to
get product data
product ID
and loop over like so
great and perhaps align it to the right
now one thing what I have to do is we've
obviously hard coded the length of this
list so go ahead and click on the list
order list View and we're just going to
change this to be however long
the get sales order detail data product
ID length
okay so in this case it will be one
as only one product is associated with
this order but if I go ahead and click
on order 10 2 5 1 you will see there are
two items associated with this order
okay
wonderful so this is looking great okay
so I think what it is done for this
section I'm just actually going to hard
code the height of this as well so the
order table I want it to be a fixed
height so that is fixed to around about
there which means that I also want to
just change the height of this just so
they're both kind of equal when we load
the app to get started okay I just think
visually that's a bit better
but once again that is totally up to you
that is a choice that you can make
next up I want to focus on getting
refunds and notifications about this
refunds by using the strike API and the
SMTP API in order to send emails so
let's do it
I'm just going to drag in the container
like so
so here we go and this is going to be
for
refunds
notifications
okay so this time I'm just going to
change the header to be a kind of
reddish color so just go ahead and
select the container I'm going to rename
this to refund
container and then let's make the header
background I'm going to make it like a
red so maybe something around here is
quite nice and I'm going to hard code
the text to be white so that doesn't
give us the default color that it wants
I'm also going to actually add a image
here to represent the Mobi company so
this is just the kind of logo that I
made feel free to not use it but I'm
going to show you that you can also
upload pictures into here so to do that
just go ahead and drag in an image like
so so that's what I have done
and there we go so there is my company
logo that I have made it's nothing
special but I think for this tutorial it
will do I'm just going to make this a
little bit smaller and move it right
back up here where it was before
so now the refund container well as we
know we're going to have to create
refunds right and to do this I actually
want to Auto populate a tab for the
employee to see exactly what their
refunding so it's really easy to read
for them when they're on the phone
perhaps and when they're composing
emails so for this I'm going to put in
another container just like so I'm not
going to have a header for this so I'm
just going to go ahead and hide the
header so just like that and in here
what I'm just going to call this text
display
container
just like that and it's going to hold
the text that we need to see so I think
the employee should have something that
says
create
refund
for and then we're gonna have to get the
customer associated with this order
number right so just like we did with
the product we're going to use that
order number to fetch data from another
table which is the customer table I'm
going to create a new query I'm going to
call this get customer and then we're
going to select
all from the table customer
where
the cost ID equals
the table
so the order tables sorry because that's
what we call this
customer ID so actually we can just use
the custom ID we don't need to use the
order number so that makes our life
easier so let's get the order
table
selected row data cost ID
okay so now let's save and run this
and wonderful so there we go if we
change the selected row it will get us a
different customer based on the customer
ID
so in here now I'm going to use that I'm
going to use the query we wrote called
get customer data and get the contact
name
great I'm just going to add an S order
just like so and then in here well
we can also use markdown if we wish so I
can choose to use markdown for this just
to show you a different way of doing
things and I'm also going to use an
emotic con which is a cute little arrow
okay so this is just some styling that I
think is a bit fun
great
and this text well I want the text to be
dark so let's just go ahead and change
that okay so now let's move that out
so create reason for Alan Michael's
order or you can change the name that
was totally up to us we just have to
change the selected row and this query
will automatically run okay because
we're changing the selected run
next up I'm just gonna essentially give
instructions to an employee on what to
do so I'm just going to put in some text
I'm just going to go ahead and put in
some text under here like so
and this text is going to say so I'm
just going to use these as it's easy for
me uh I'm gonna have a one which is to
check order
details so you're telling the employee
to check the order details and we can
actually show them so this is for
order
number and we're going to go enter the
order table
selected row data and get the order ID
so it's really obvious which order
they're looking at and the text I'm just
going to do this dark color again
then we're going to have made on
and then we're going to use the date
that this order was made on so we're
going to go into the order table
selected row order date however it will
show it in this format as a default
we're going to pass it through into the
new day object and change it to a date
string so I'm going to do so by getting
the new date JavaScript object and
passing through the whole thing so the
order date and then using the method of
two date string on it okay so there we
go that's a much more readable format
for us and let's just go ahead and put a
dot now I can use a space I can space
this out Simply by adding this snippet
of code so if you feel the need to do
that just go ahead and add
that
okay great we can do the same here
now the other piece of text that I want
to add is the when the order was shipped
so I'm going to put this order was
shipped on V and once again I'm actually
just going to get the new date objects
as I now know I need to use it in order
to change the format of the date and I'm
going to go into the order table I'm
going to get this selected row I'm going
to get that data and I'm going to get
the ship
date
so shipped date
so there we go and I'm going to use the
method of two date string on it in order
to change it to a readable format
without the time
so that's when the order was shipped to
and then we're going to put the address
so we're going to once again go into the
order table selectory data and get the
ship address however it was spelled on
the original
database okay not what we changed it to
here
great so that's where it was shipped to
and then we're going to also have the
ship City so once again the order table
selected row data shipped City and then
as well as the country so just go ahead
and add the country too
okay
so
order table select little data ship
country
wonderful so I think this is looking
really good the next thing I want to do
is actually show the items associated
with the order again just in a smaller
way so once again we're going to use the
list View
so let's just drag and drop that in here
let's call this order
mini list here and this time I think
we'll just show the picture but a really
small picture in here so I'm just going
to drag in an image
like so
as well as some text for the title I'm
also going to have the unit price
and the quantity as well so I'm just
going to change that to be an individual
text on right here
okay
so not as good to looping I'm just going
to use the get product query again so
I'm going to get
product data
photo
open up I and loop and do the same for
the title so get
product data
product name and loop
and I'm just going to change the text to
be a darker color so we can read it as
perhaps also make this in bold so I'm
just going to put it in
these two stars and then we're gonna get
the product so once again use the Stars
get product data
unit price and loop
just finish that off change the text to
be darker
and I'm just going to put unit price in
front of this so unit price just like so
and then we're also going to have the
quantity so maybe we move that down just
so we can put this on one line like this
and then the quantity we'll put here or
perhaps if we want let's actually make
this smaller so I don't really think it
needs to be that big which means we can
move all of these up to two I think that
makes more sense for what we are really
building here okay it's just a tiny
little checkup for our employees so they
don't have to go looking through all the
data
okay and this time we're actually going
to get the sales order so get sales
order detail data quantity to find out
how much of each product was bought okay
so let's just go ahead and put quantity
here quantity
and then let's change the color of the
text
great
so this is looking wonderful and of
course we want the order mini list view
to change dynamically based on the get
sales order
detail data
product ID
length
great so now if we click on this order
which I know has two products we should
get the two products associated with it
on a phone
next up we're going to select the refund
type so for this I'm actually going to
do a select drop down so I'm just going
to drag this in here this is a new
component that we haven't used yet and
it's going to allow us to select
something from a drop down that we can
use in order to populate our email
okay so there we go I'm going to
position
the label to be at the top I'm going to
change the default text
to be a dark color and now we can also
change the label text itself so here's
the label and this is going to say two
select refund type
okay and now we're going to put in the
options for this
so I can choose to do this manually or I
can just choose to do the mapped version
and I'm going to put an array that has
the options of late in core
correct
and unsatisfactory
and now for the label well let's just go
ahead and get up our Kylie braces open
up an array and we're going to actually
show what the labels of these options
are the first one is going to say order
was late by over 10. days
then the second one is going to say
incorrect damaged
order and the third one is going to say
unsatisf Factory
and we're gonna
Loop
I'm also going to choose to have the
default option as being late okay and
once again I'm just going to change the
text of this
to be a dark color
so wonderful and we also need to change
some other texts it would seem like
highlighted foreground
just make it dark so there we go so now
if we select one it should show up here
and this is looking good and then we can
select other ones too and of course we
can change this as much as we want okay
great let's move on the next thing I
want to put in is the refund amount and
I'm going to do so with a number input
this time so just go ahead and select
one of these we can put a number we can
actually put currency so perhaps let's
go ahead and put currency as I feel that
makes more sense so just drag that in
and this should say amount to be
refunded so amount to refund
[Music]
and then people can just select the
amount in U.S dollars okay so feel free
to change the currency if you wish I'm
happy working in American dollars for
this project
next I'm just going to do a little quick
recap so a little summary
so I'm just going to put refund summary
like so
okay
and then I'm just going to under this
refund summary
just display the actual refund amount to
refund amount
and then whatever
the number input or the currency input
value is I want to just display here as
a quick summary and let's put that in
bold and I'm just going to put US
dollars
okay so there we go we can even have US
dollars in here to make that bold too
great and once we've kind of checked all
this I just want to have a button so I'm
going to add in a button to actually
commit the refund so let the refund
happen so let's just go ahead and put a
button in here
and put in a button let's call this
refund and I'm just going to make it
green okay so let me make it green
perhaps let's make it a little bit
lighter too
so there we have our refund button and
let's also change the text to be white
wonderful so I feel this is done I'm
quite happy with this okay
great now let's use this information to
compose an email so we can send an email
as well as well as come at the refund
and we'll be using the stripe API in
order to hook this up to the refund
button to actually make that refund
happen back onto the charge but first
like I said let's do the email so let's
put on another container I'm just going
to work in a container in here
once again I'm just going to get rid of
the heading so we don't need to show the
header for this
I'm going to search for a component
called text input so I'm just going to
use the text input folders just like so
change the label to be at the top
so I'm just going to change the position
to be top and I'm just going to
essentially change the label to be three
compose email as step number three for
the employee
okay and let's also go ahead and put
another input for the actual email so
it's going to be a text input this time
just going to whack that in here
and this is just going to say email and
we're gonna have a placeholder that just
says info at test.com
okay
great
so there we go I want to change the
color of this container in fact this
should probably be called email
container so email can
container and the color of this so I'm
just going to make a really light red so
just like so
wonderful
and now I don't want this to be Auto I
want it to be fixed I'm just going to
drag it so it's always the same length
just like that
okay let's move a little bit bigger and
that means I can move this down to the
bottom and I'm also going to have a big
button so let's go ahead and create and
add a button here
and this button is going to span all the
way here I'm going to change the text to
send
email
and I'm going to change this to be red
okay so all of this section is kind of
red and in here well I'm actually going
to write a JavaScript transformer for
the email text
because we're gonna have to write a few
things in here so I'm going to change
this to the email text
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
define a message that we're going to
return
okay so my message is going to be I'm
just going to use some back ticks for
this
dear and then we're going to get
the get customer data
contacts name
for comma
I am sorry that your order was and then
we're gonna have a reason from our
selected option so whatever we select so
I'm going to actually get it from the
select I'm going to call this the refund
select
input
so now we can actually grab the refund
select input and get it to Value so we
can display it making sure that this is
actually in three curly braces this time
okay so just make sure that looks like
that otherwise it won't get picked up
properly and then let's put please rest
assured that your refund of and then
once again on a kind of basis double
quality braces now so it should be three
in total
and we're gonna get the refund amount of
the number input so currency one value
US Dollars has been also authorized
and shall be with you in one to five
working days
okay and then let's put have a wonderful
day great so that is our full message
and now let's go ahead and just return
the message okay so that's what will be
returned when we use the email text
Transformer
great so I think we actually need to
space this out from the Kali braces like
so so just like touch
okay so now it's being picked up
so let's save this and now all I'm going
to do is in here under the default text
I'm going to get the email text value
great perhaps the text area is actually
better for this so let's go ahead and do
that
and once again get the email text value
okay so I think maybe that's a bit
better
so just go ahead and delete that text
input and I'm also going to hard code
Auto growth with content so I'm going to
change this to be 14 just so it's a
little bit bigger and just move it up
here and I'll change this label to be
three compost
email
wonderful
so this is looking so so much better
and just align that email to go to the
right okay so that is looking good we
could of course mess around with this as
much as we want that part is totally up
to us and our house let's just make that
water
great now let's get to hooking this up
so the first thing I'm going to do is
just go to stripe so if you haven't used
stripe before please go ahead and sign
up to the developer portal I'm just
going to go ahead and sign in so just go
ahead and sign in like that this is what
it should look like once you've signed
up and you are returning back as a user
and under here so here's the URL that
you should be able to see and the test
data tab is where we're going to be
doing our magic so under payments is
where you can actually create a new
payment and you will do so by selecting
this here so for example I can make a
fake payment of 340 pounds and then we
can actually just go ahead and put in
some test card information so if you go
ahead and search for stripe test cards
then this should come up with this
documentation right here and we can
essentially use this fake card number so
copy that and then paste it in here and
then just for anything in the future so
I'm going to put 20 25 just like so and
put one two three okay so the future
will be 25. so oops we need a
description so mobile phone as well as
the ZIP code
and click submit
okay great and then if you view the
details
so just go ahead and view the detail you
will see a fake charge ID
so the ID that we need is this one right
here this is the charge ID it starts
with ch and if you look in here I've
actually given the same charge ID to all
of my sales orders okay so this charge
ID is what we're going to be using to
make a refund
so hopefully you understand how I got
that charge ID now so I'm just going to
go ahead and go back to here
and I'm going to create a new resource
query and I'm just going to go ahead and
create a new resource I'm just going to
go back in here
create new resource and look for stripe
now I'm just going to call this
Moby app
stripe
and then the API Key Well to get this
we're going to have to find our API key
right so let's go ahead and shut this
down I'm going to search for API
developer API keys and here is my key
so this is the one I'm going to need I'm
going to copy this one so copy it please
go ahead and make your own of course and
I am just going to under here paste that
in and test the connection and
connection successful I'm going to
create a resource okay so great I'm
going to go back to resources go back to
my app hit refresh as we're going to
need to load that new resource in here
create a new resource query search for
the Mobi app stripe resource and under
here we're going to search for an
operation that is going to be a post to
a refund so I'm just going to search for
that in here it's a post request I'm
going to post a refund so that should
probably be down here
just make sure to find the correct one
as there is a lot in here
is this poster charges getting the
charge refund
okay and the charge well it's going to
be we're going to go into the order
table I'm going to get the selected row
data and the charge ID okay so at the
moment as it says demo all our charge
IDs are the same but each one of these
rules should really have a different
charge ID in the real life and then
we're gonna have to send through the
amount we want to refund so we're going
to use the currency one value so this
components of value okay and we're just
going to save that
and I'm just going to rename this to
post refund and to on success so we want
to know that this works I'm going to add
just a confetti okay so so confetti will
be thrown in the air if this works so
let's go ahead and try this out I'm just
going to go ahead and select an order so
the first one
this is for this order and as you can
see there's one item of quantity one and
then the unit price so I'm just going to
go ahead and refund let's say 100 from
it and then of course we need to link
this up to the query that we wrote so
I'm just going to go ahead and on the
button I'm going to add an event handler
which is to control the query post
refund so now let's go ahead and click
that button and ta-da that has worked as
the confetti has run and if you look
down here you will see amazing so this
is the response that we get
let's go ahead and try another one so
I'm just going to select perhaps this
line
so there we go we have the unit price of
course this unit price does not
correlate to the charge ID because we
just put on a random number however I'm
just showing you how this works and if I
was to refund fifty dollars this time to
whatever the charge ID has on it and
refund
Tada that has worked and you will see
that a refund has been made to the same
charge ID essentially like I said this
is not realistic I'm using test data you
will see that that has worked okay that
is actually the total amount refunded
now because I refunded 100 earlier I
just 350 and I refunded 100 earlier when
I was testing this out as well so that
is the total amount refunded and that
was the original amount that we had
great
so that is not working let's carry on
so we've hooked this up to the stripe
API next I want to hook this up to
actually sending an email so let's do
that next I'm just going to minimize all
of this right now
okay and we don't need this anymore
either
okay so to do this we're going to get
another new resource this time I'm going
to use the Gmail resource so let's go
ahead and actually go in here and create
that resource specifically for this
project I'm going to create a new
resource and then we're going to search
for the
SMTP resource let's call this Mobi
mailing
SMTP
the host for this is going to be SMTP
gmail.com the port is 465 and then I'm
just going to use Anya at
freecodecamp.org
okay so this is the email that it's
going to be sent out from essentially
and that I'm gonna have to put in my
password okay so just go ahead and do
that too
okay and just test the connection
you might get some errors even though
you're putting your correct password so
just check your email and just confirm
it with you and then just go ahead and
allow access to less secure apps okay so
that has now been done which means that
if we go back in here now and try that
again so test connection that should
work okay so great that's how you would
fix that let's go ahead and just remove
all these and make sure to perhaps maybe
if you want and of course if you don't
feel safe doing it then you don't have
to there are other options that you can
use for mailing okay great so that has
our work let's go back here and refresh
this page so just reload it in order to
get that latest resource and then on
this query 10 I'm going to now use the
movie
mailing SMTP the two email well that's
just going to be the text input too so
let's get text input to Value uh the
subject is going to be regarding order
and then let's get the order table
selected real data order ID and then the
body is just going to be the text area
one so let's get text area one value
okay and once again on success let's
just get up some confetti
wonderful so that is good and let's save
this as something so save that and let's
rename this to send
email and on click of this button we're
going to trigger it so add an event
handler send email and great so now
let's test it out I'm just going to send
this to Anya at three
codecamp.org and send the email
and wonderful that seems to have worked
let's go check it out
great there we go so that is working
we've done everything that we needed to
do for this employee app this is the
final product I hope you've enjoyed
coding this along with me and I hope
you're ready for the second part of this
course where we're going to learn how to
make an admin panel where we not only
read data but we also add data delete
data and edit data too so let's do it
okay so let's start building our admin
app or in other words our Mobi Manager
application as I've chosen to call it so
let's go ahead and create that new app
I'm going to choose to call it Moby
Manager application just like so and go
ahead and create that app so once again
you'll be given this boilerplate default
setup and I'm just going to delete this
and I'm going to delete the query that
we have here
okay
great so now that we have done that I
want to have two main components
essentially one is for viewing our
employees as a list as well as deleting
employees or editing their details if we
wish and on the right I'm gonna have an
inventory section where we can see all
of our inventory as well as delete lines
or add new lines okay so this is going
to be a great example of how to add data
delete data and edit data from our
database so let's do it we of course
going to be using the exact same
database that the employee database is
using as is frequently seen in companies
so first off I'm just going to create a
container so there we go that is our
container and let's go ahead and call
this
employees just like so and I'm just
gonna make the header of this container
a different color so I'm just going to
select
this kind of reddish color right here
and I'm just going to make the text
White
okay
so there we go and now I'm going to drop
in another container this time this is
going to be for the inventory so let's
go ahead and change this to say in
then Tori
making sure to spell it correctly and
I'm going to change the header of this
to also be a different color let's go
with the greenish color this time that
I've kind of pre-selected so I like this
green right here
okay and it's also make the font White
wonderful
so we did say that we want a list view
here so let's go ahead and select the
list view container just like so and
just drop it in so I've dropped that in
here we can of course rename these if we
wish so let's go ahead and rename this
to employee
container
and then we're gonna have this as
inventory
container but of course you don't have
to that is just my choice now on the
list view I'm going to actually rename
this to view
Glory
list
View
okay
and in here I'm just gonna have an image
of the employee as well as their name so
we're going to have their name here
let's just go ahead and make this an H3
element I think that should be fine with
their name
and then let's change the text of this
to be a dark color just like so I'm just
going to make it this dark grayish
I'm also going to put in an icon so this
icon is going to be to delete this
employee so let's go ahead and find a
delete icon
so this one right here and then change
the color of it
to be once again a dark color
and I'm just going to make this a lot
smaller as well so there we go and I've
got the name here we can make this as
small as we wish
okay
so great and then let's have some text
which is going to be for whatever the
title is so we can have something like
titled here and of course let's change
the text again to a darker color
just make it the same
and then we've got the title another
thing we can have is the employee ID so
let's go ahead and change this to the
employee ID and I'm just going to put
this on the other side so I'm just going
to drag it in here like so
then we're gonna have the address
so let's just change this address and
make this in bold
and then
first line of the address and whatever
really address related things we have in
here so I think it was City we can of
course change these uh then we have the
region
we also have the country and postcode so
let's go ahead and mount that
country
postal code
okay and perhapses also have a divider
because why not just under the title
just to make it a little bit more
visually appealing as we want to space
out the address from the title and then
I'm also going to have a button here so
that we can edit
I'm gonna have this as edit and make it
red so you can edit the improve you okay
great so this is looking good I like the
look of that now let's go ahead and get
our data so I'm going to create a new
resource query and this is going to be
to get all the employees
okay so this is going to be to our
managed database
just like so I'm going to select
pull from
employee and save and one
okay great which means we can now
populate this list with that so I'm
actually going to get the employee data
let's go by the employee ID
and then length Okay as that should be
unique so you've got three employees
that looks good and now the picture here
I'm going to once again go into get
employee data
get the photo and then Loop by passing
through an eye and do the same for the
name
so once again get employee data we're
going to get the first name this time
and loop and then I'm just going to go
to space and get the employee data last
name to and again
so actually we need to put the first one
in Cali braces and finish that off and
then open up our cardio braces again and
then just put a space
wonderful the title well we're just
going to go into get employee data once
more get the title and loop
and then the employee ID
let's go into the employee data get the
amp ID and move
okay so you're getting the juice now the
first line of the address get employee
data and then this time it's going to be
the
address
and loop
space that out the city
is once again get employee's data City
and loop
this time the region so get employee
data
region and loop
country you can of course display as
much information or as little as you
want that's part is totally up to you
you have all the data to your disposal
and finding the postal code so get
employee data
postal code
and
yep
okay now I'm actually going to put in
another divider so I can put the contact
detail and the birthday of this employee
because this is admin level stuff right
we didn't want every employee to see it
but
as an admin you are privy to this
information so I'm simply going to put
the phone number so let's put phone and
then go into the get employee data
the phone and loop
let's change this text as well
to be a darker color making sure that's
the same as the others
and I'm just going to copy paste this
and replace the second line with
hired and then we're going to get into
the
higher date and then we probably want to
pass this through the new day object so
let's go ahead and do that and if our
new day object
and then get the method of two date
string and just call it
okay so then we've got the higher date
and then let's have the and now let's
have the birth date too so
birthday and then this time we're gonna
get the
birth date
great so that is our employees now that
we have done that let's get you writing
our query for updating an employee but
to do that I'm actually going to show
you how to make a modal so I'm just
going to actually minimize this and
instead of having a button I actually
want to change this to be a Moodle so a
modal pop-up so just go ahead and drag
that in here like so it looks the same
but it has different functionality so
let's just change this to edit and I'm
just going to make it a little bit
smaller and once again just change the
color to the red
okay but this time when we click on this
it will open up a module so let's go
ahead and put what we want in this
module and that is
some text to let us know what this model
is all about so I'm going to change this
to say edit employee
just like so
and of course change this
to be a darker color
now let's have a text input because
we're going to have text inputs we're
also going to populate these text inputs
with the data from this employee as a
default okay so once again just change
the text color and place it with the one
we're using so our first label well this
is just going to be the first name of
the employee
and as a default value we're going to go
into the get employees data and get the
first name
and just Loop over it okay so that was
really easy and the text is just going
to be this dark of text so just like so
so now let's copy and paste this and
this time this is going to say last name
so let's go up here I'm just going to
change the state last name and the
default text is going to be the last
name okay so hopefully you'll get what
we're doing here we're going to do the
same for the title
so title and then we're gonna have the
title of the employee showing up here
but then I'm gonna have the birth date
so let's go ahead and put
birth date this time I'm going to leave
it like so therefore ever because I
think it's quite important to
differentiate between the two so there's
our birth date and how it converts to
that when we view on here but when we
enter it it looks like this
this is going to be the higher date so
let's go ahead and pick out the higher
date this time and the birth date so
higher date from our database next we're
going to have the address
so I'm going to put a dress
and then I'm going to pick out the
address
next we're going to have the city
let's have the city
pick out the city
and then we're gonna have the region
so pick out the region and have a label
as region and then we're going to have a
postal code
so let's have a personal code
and just change this Crystal
go to the video that's what we want
then we're just gonna have country
and I'm just going to change the same
country
and then the phone number so phone
let's change this to phone and then a
URL so of course you probably would have
a photo database for this but for the
sake of this tutorial I'm just going to
link to photos by URLs that are hosted
online okay so that's what I've done
here I've essentially got them from
unsplash so I'm just going to get the
photo
this is going to say photo and lastly
I'm just going to have the employee ID
so this should be a number so let's go
ahead and put number input so number
input
just like so stretch this out let's
change the text
so these contrast text here will change
to be the same color as all the others
and do it for the actual text too so
there we go and I'm just going to change
it to say employee ID
so employee
ID
great and now I'm going to get a button
so just put that in here like so and
this is to update so put that in
and change this to update and on the
click of this we want to run a query
right and that is to edit or update an
employee so let's call this update
employee and for this we're going to do
it to the manage database and SQL that
we're going to write for this is so
we're gonna
updates
employee
set
first name equals and then we're gonna
get now to find the text input it's text
input one so that's what we're going to
do we're going to get text text inputs
one value then we're going to have to
set last name and that is text input two
so let's get text input choose value
then we have to get the title and you
guessed it that is going to be text
input 3 and there it is test info 3's
value then we get the birth date so
birth date
making sure that it's the correct one so
text input value for the higher
date
which is text input 5 value
the address
which is
six so let's find text input six value
the city
which is text input seven so let's go
ahead and find that one
the region
which is text
input H value
the postal code
which is nine so let's find that one
the country
just 10 so let's find text input 10
and we've got the phone number which is
11.
so text input value 11.
nearly that photos next photo
text input value 12 this time
then we have the employee ID which is
number input one so amp
ID
which is
number input value one
great and we search for it by the
employee ID which is why we need to put
where
and ID equals
and then we're going to get the
employee but based off
this right here
so we could go into the get employees
and loop I think a better way to do this
would be to I'm just going to save this
minimize that is to get this employee ID
so in fact I'm going to split this out
and I'm going to make another so I'm
just gonna
duplicate this
and I'm just going to have the employee
ID in its own text so just like so and
move that here and I'm just going to
have the label as a separate one okay so
that's what I've done I'm going to move
this up here now
space that back up here
and just select all of these and move
them up a little bit too
so now I can grab text 14
14
value
and search for the employee to update by
that okay so now I'm going to save and
what I'm going to do is actually
now add an event handled to this but on
the success of this I'm just going to
add some confetti so that we know this
has worked so save that and click on the
button and I'll add a Transformer to an
event handler and the query for this is
going to be to update the employee so
great so now let's check it out
I'm just going to change Sarah's name to
have an H at the end update
and great so that has worked and next we
need to actually refetch that data so on
success we send some confetti and we
also rerun the query to get employees
okay so we're refreshing that data we're
getting it again just run that
and great so that has now been updated
and Sarah Davis has actually dropped to
the end okay wonderful so this is all
looking
great I'm really happy with this
perhaps you can even give it some
spacing in between each of these so I'm
just going to add some spaces just like
so you can do so or you can choose not
to that part is totally up to you
okay
great
so now to delete an employee so for this
I'm actually going to write another
query and that is going to be to delete
employee just like so
and to delete the employee I'm going to
use the delete keyword
from the employee database where the amp
ID equals the text 14
value so once again we're just using the
value of this text right here okay so
that's all I'm going to do and unsuccess
once again I'm just going to add some
confetti so you know this works and
we're also going to have to refetch all
that data so get employees again and
save okay so now let's try and delete
someone from here
I'm just going to go ahead and attach
that to this icon right here so add an
event listener or delete employee so I'm
just going to click on here let's get
rid of this so you see what this looks
like delete Dawn funk
and great so don Funk is now deleted to
Adam we would have to go back into our
database and re-add that data okay but
he's gone for now
you can of course add a button to add
new employees in here but we're just
going under the assumption that this
data is coming from elsewhere and we as
managers just have the ability to edit
the employee or delete them okay so that
is the assumption that I am going under
to add new things I'm going to show you
how to do that in the inventory so once
you gain that knowledge you can apply it
to this section too so let's do it
for the inventory however I'm going to
write a new query which is to get
inventory so get
inventory just like so and this time I'm
going to select
all from
product okay and save and run so just go
ahead and do that and I'm going to get a
table and as we are on this query it
should populate with data from that
query okay wonderful
now again the text here is very light so
just go ahead and change this I'm just
gonna change it in here
to be a darker color just like so
and that looks good
wonderful so now that we have that I'm
going to show you how to create a custom
column on this table so I'm just going
to call this inventory
table
and I'm going to create a new column
this is going to be to delete
so hence I'm just going to call it
delete
and the column type is actually going to
be a button so let's go ahead and search
for the button just like so and the
value is just going to say delete
okay so great and we're going to have to
add it on click however we need to write
the query for that I'm just going to
move this up so it's the first right
here
on the four next I'm also going to add
an option to add an inventory item so
once again I'm going to have a mode up
so let's go ahead and search for the
middle I'm just going to pop it in here
I'm going to make this green
so just like that and I'm going to
change the text as maybe put this a
little bit lighter
to
just the word add okay so just like that
great and on this model well just like
we did before I'm gonna have to create
some inputs right but this time we're
just going to leave them blank so let's
go ahead and create I'm just going to
drag in some text in here and this is
going to say add a product so add a
product
just like so and then I'm just going to
put in some inputs so this is going to
be a let's have the ID first so let's
put that in here I'm just going to drag
that over let's not forget to change the
text of this to be a darker color so I'm
just going to whack that in here same
for this one so let's go down here and
change the contrast color the label as
well as the actual text as well
so there we go we have a label here
that's meant to be for our ID so I'm
just going to change this to say
product ID and what is cool is that we
can make this required so I can just go
ahead and flip this and that is now
required
next let's have a text input I'm just
going to drag that in here like so I'm
just going to change the text of this
so once again I'm just going to change
it to be that
and let's change the label of this I'm
going to just change it to view
product
name
just like so and I'm going to make this
required
I'm also going to have a photo URL so
you can put on a photo of the product
itself then we're also going to have
units in stock
so I'm just going to change say units in
stock
as well as a unit price which should be
in currency so let's put in a currency
section just like so
so that we go and change the text of
this as well
and finally we're going to have a text
area so look for a text area and just
drag it in I'm going to change the label
and this should say product description
and great and then we're just going to
have a button that will let us add to
our database so once again I'm just
going to put add just like that
and let's write our queries so I'm going
to write a new resource query this time
to add
product
and this time well there should be a
flashback to our data base that you saw
on GitHub we're going to use insert into
then we're going to find the table
called products
okay
we're going to open up a parenthesis and
describe the columns so we're going to
have the product ID
good product
name making sure to spell exactly the
same as I am the product this
description
the unit price
units in stock
Andy photo
okay and then the values that we're
going to insert which are the number
input 2 value
the text input 13 value
the text area one value the currency one
value
I need text input 14 value
great and on success we are going to
let's get our [ __ ] on fatty
and let's also rerun the data so get the
inventory again and then let's also
shot the components so control component
and let's get the modal two and I just
want to close it okay
great so let's save that
and now let's go ahead and try this out
I'm going to put product four product
name it's going to be test
should change the text of this as well
so just make that darker
test mobile
put in a random URL
just copy the link address of that
paste it in like so I'm just going to
change the text of this two units in
stock I'm going to put 12
say this costs 400 dollars
and then let's just put a test
and of course let's not forget to add
the units in stock which is number input
three
okay and now let's hook this up to an
event handler so this is going to run
the query add product and then it's
going to minimize this so you can see
hit add
and great so that has worked we have got
the inventory again and that has been
added for us wonderful now one last
thing is we want to run the delete query
so once again let's get up our queries
let's make a new query I'm going to call
this delete
product just like so and I'm going to
delete
from product where
products ID equals I want to go into the
inventory table so the inventory table
selected wrote data product ID
okay once again on success I'm going to
show you some confetti so add that and
I'm also going to rerun the data so
control query
select the query get inventory again
great so those two are added let's click
save and now let's link this up so the
delete column on click we want to run a
query and that is the delete
product query right so now let's test it
out I'm just going to delete the one we
made
and wonderful so great we can now add
things delete things and update things
in our database this is looking
wonderful
and now finally I'm just going to build
a revenue tracker so all I'm going to do
is just drag in another container just
like so drag it over all the way to the
end
I'm going to call this Revenue tracker
so let's go ahead and put Revenue
tracker unless we get a fun of blue
because why not so I'm just going to
select the actual container and then the
header I'm just going to select this
blue color right here
okay and now I'm going to put in a
tabbed container so let's put it in
another tabbed container just like this
okay because we're going to have a table
and then we're going to actually show
some historical data too
so I'm actually going to write a new
query so resource query this time it's
going to be a query Json with SQL and
we're going to essentially select all
from and then we are going to get the
order detail but we're also going to use
the method of format datas as array so
make it into an array we're going to
pass through the get order detail
data but of course for this to work
we're going to have to you guess it get
the order detail so I'm just going to
save this it won't work and let's create
a new resource query called get order
detail just making sure to spell it
exactly the same way as we did
and this is going to be once again to
our manage database
I'm going to select
or prompt order
detail and save and run
okay so now back in here that's what
we're getting and we're going to join it
with
the sales order so once again we're
going to format data as array
we're going to pass through get sales
order
so all of the sales orders so this one
is easy just save that we did in the
previous part of this tutorial we're
going to get sales
orders this is going to be a managed
database I'm going to select all from
sales order and save and run
okay
and then
orders order ID we're going to match
both by order ID
okay and we save and run this
ta-da we get all that data but it's been
joined together I'm going to show you
what it looks like in a table as I think
that'd be better I'm going to call this
joined Revenue
data
and then I'm just going to put in a
table right here
using the joint Revenue data okay
so there we go
and we can even add our own custom
column if we wish so I'm going to go
ahead and just call this
total amount
and then the value we're going to put in
is just the current
row quantity
multiplied by the current row
unit price
okay and that will show us the total
amount so the unit price multiplied by
this quantity value
okay
great and we can even move that here
so let's go ahead and rename this
alltran
sections and on view two well one of you
two I want this to be historical data so
I'm just going to put historical
data and then let's delete view through
so now under here what I'm gonna do is
use the graph
so just like so just drag that in
like that
and as the x-axis we're going to have
the order date because it's going to be
historical and then we're going to group
by the ship country so let's find the
ship country we're going to stack the
group data and we're going to add a new
data set
so just double click on that and let's
call this joined Revenue data and in
here well we're going to format
data as object this time we're going to
pass through the joined Revenue data and
we're going to get the
unit price we're going to go into it and
look for the
unit
price
we're going to map
whatever is in the array
to
the joined
Revenue data
quantity
okay just making sure that we are
actually including the amount of items
that were purchased okay each time
and just make sure to actually spell
everything correctly okay so there we go
that is what you need to do
I'm just going to put order date on here
on the x-axis let's make this a date the
y-axis going to be the total revenue
and now I'm just going to actually hide
all the rest of these
and wonderful we have done it
okay so all our transactions
and then our historical data
and of course we can make this as big as
small as we want but now we know exactly
how much money was made on each day so
on July the 9th for example
696 dollars were made and if we look in
here on July the 9th
that makes sense as we sold two items at
the unit price of three four eight so
the total amount was 696.
okay and finally it's time for our last
app again using the same database and
that is to build a developer portal an
internal tool for developers to
essentially get endpoints to the Mobi
database so let's do it I'm going to
create a new app and this time I'm going
to call it Mobi developer application
just like so and hit that bottom again
we're just going to delete all the
default things that come with this app
so I'm going to delete this query too
now our developer portal I'm just going
to actually drag in some text so that
people know what this is I'm going to
use an H1 element this time let's go
ahead and do that and I'm just going to
call this a developer portal just like
so and just drag that over and then
let's also just have a little subtitle
so everyone knows what this is for
this is going to say get and points to
the
Moby
data base
okay
wonderful and for this I'm going to use
another cool component that we haven't
used yet and that is the collapsible so
collapsible container so let's just go
ahead and drag that in here
and wonderful now this first container
well let's just go ahead and select it
I'm going to change the header of this
to have this kind of bluish color that I
have
chosen
okay just like that and the title of
this is going to be for the end point to
get all our sales orders so I'm just
going to go ahead and change this to get
sales
orders
just like so okay
now in here I'm just going to drag in
some text this is going to say
I'm going to use markdown this time get
sales orders API endpoint
to
retrieve all sales orders
and next I'm going to create a table so
I'm just going to drag in a table like
so
and instead of having this I'm just
going to write my own data for this
so I'm going to open up an array to
create my table and then I'm just going
to create my first object my first
object is just going to have
the method type and this is going to be
a get
request so I'm just going to put get as
the HTTP request method and the end
point
is going to be
sales
making sure that's in quotes
orders for example
and then we're gonna have the action
foreign
okay so I'm just making what I imagine a
developer portal might look like when it
comes to viewing the different endpoints
we can have to a database okay so of
course this is just for demo purposes
next we might be able to filter so I'm
just going to add that and the endpoint
is going to be sales orders and then
we're going to pass through an ID as a
parameter which is going to have a value
okay and then let's just have a few more
so this time we're going to have get
pagination endpoint is going to be sales
orders and then we're going to have
the page for example two and a limit of
10.
we could even make this just for
anything to do with sales orders right
so if we want to add to the sales order
we could do that as well it would just
go to the sales orders endpoint just
like so just say well if you want to
update so this would be a put request
and then we'd have to actually find
whichever order we want to
update essentially and then we're also
going to have a delete write which again
we're going to have to supply the order
that we want to delete
great so that's what it would look like
let's actually go ahead and change this
to sales orders a API I'm going to
retrieve add edit and delete sales
orders
right I think
that's fine I'm happy with that
okay and I'm just going to make this a
little bit bigger so that everything
fits
I'm just going to make this a little bit
bigger too so that everything
that's
great
and I'm just gonna change this to get
post
put
delete
sales orders
wonderful so I've said this as an action
however I actually want to change this
to a button so let's go ahead and do
that here I'm going to change this to a
button let's search for button just like
so
wonderful now what do I want to copy
well I want to actually copy all of the
data that we supposedly get back
so I'm just gonna go ahead and do this
by going on click copy to clipboard and
next I'm just going to put in another
component in here so let's just go ahead
and make this a little bit smaller
next up we're just going to drag in a
table and we're going to populate this
with our get sales order data so let's
go ahead and write that query down here
I'm going to create a query I'm going to
call it get sales order data so get
sales
order data I'm going to make sure that
this is to the manage database so the
same one and I'm going to select all
from
sales order and save and run okay great
now that means let's go ahead and get
rid of that for now then we can populate
this table with our get sales order data
just like so so we've got the query and
we've got the data that comes back from
the query
great I'm actually going to go ahead and
put this in a tabbed container so I'm
just dragging that over here and the
first view that we're going to have is
to see the sample
response
and let's have the second view as the
table if someone wants to see the data
as a table so I'm just going to go ahead
and put table like that and then let's
get rid of you three as we don't need it
so now under table I'm just going to
drag in this table just like so so that
we can view that data
just like so I'm just going to make it
smaller
just so it fits on the same line another
sample responses
I'm going to get the Json Explorer
element so just like so put that in here
and perhaps actually let's make this
stretch out all the way as we can take
up this Blank Space right here
stretch that out to the bottom as well
okay and the same for the table
and now instead of having this sample
data we're going to get rid of that
and I'm going to show you how you can
generate an API for demonstration
purposes thanks to retool all you're
going to do is just click on get started
just like so and we're going to upload a
CSV and to do this we're actually going
to download this table right here so
just go ahead and download the data as a
CSV file and then drag it in here
and hit next and there we go so now that
we've got that
I want you to click next
and let's go ahead and call our API the
same thing that we called it here says
sales orders and everything will
suddenly make sense and generate the API
and great okay so you will see this
which we've already written here okay so
here we have all the end points to this
generated API I'm just going to copy
this endpoint URL go on the sample
responses and
create a new resource query this time we
want to call it get sales orders
or order data from rest API
we're going to use the rest query I'm
going to get from this endpoint URL and
click save and run
okay so great so now I can use that
on the sample response so let's go ahead
and use get sales order data from rest
API data
wonderful so that is looking good
so now let's go ahead and link up these
we're going to copy
this URL so once again that endpoint and
let's get rid of the sales order bit as
that is the endpoint that we need to add
in addition to this okay so then I'm
just going to go into
table one and get these selected row
data
endpoint okay and kind of add that all
together but we would have to get rid of
the dots dot dots but perhaps let's just
do that as I think that looks quite cool
so I'm just going to go ahead and delete
these dot dots from here
okay we could have course done this in
JavaScript too but to save time I'm just
going to delete them from this hard
copied text
wonderful
so now if we click on one of these you
will get the full URL
great and then if we paste it in here
like so
we get the first sales order
okay so this is just kind of a demo
purposes of course this is not live data
it's just what we generated from a CSV
right here
we can of course do this for all the
major end points so you've got the sales
orders let's go ahead and do customers
as well so I'm just going to copy and
paste the entire thing
and then let's change the title of this
to customers
let's also change the color of this I'm
just going to make a lighter green just
like this color right here I have
pre-picked out
change what it says in here so this time
let's have it say customers API endpoint
retrieve add edit and delete
customers and then of course we're gonna
have to change them all in here too
customers
get
customers
it's also have to add a customer to the
customers pagination
customers
edit a customer and customers
and delete a customer from
Custer
verse okay so that is looking good and
it's going to copy that but of course we
need to get the right uh URL so I'm
going to actually get rid of the data
from this table so just go ahead and
delete that let's get up
our little dashboard for making queries
and this time we're going to make
another query it's going to be called
get customers it's going to be to our
manage database
and we're going to select all
from customer save and run
Okay so we've got that so now we can use
it here for our table get customers data
just like so I'm going to minimizers at
the bottom so we're getting all of our
customers I'm going to download this
again and it's generating new apis I'm
just going to actually refresh this page
and I'm going to drag that in here like
so I'm also going to click next okay so
those that is actually all of our
customer data and then I'm going to
click next again let's call our API
customers generate the API and great so
now let's copy that
get our sample response
and once again we're going to have to
write a new query I'm going to call this
get customers
data
from
rest API we're going to
like a rest query I'm going to get our
customers save and run
okay so now I'm going to minimize this
and that is what I'm going to use for
the value here get customer data from
rest API data just like so and the
action here well the action here is
going to be to copy let's get our action
table three customers okay so this is
looking good that is table three so
let's check it out let's copy this one
and indeed if we are selecting the right
row it does copy that to our clipboard
okay great
so we have to I'm just going to do one
more but you kind of get the gist now so
once more I'm just going to copy the
whole thing and paste it like so this
time I'm gonna have for employees
let me change the color of this
to be a kind of
reddish color
this time this is going to say
pure use API I'm going to retrieve add
edit and delete
employees
just get rid of that and once again I'm
just going to make a query so resource
query call this get employ use this is
going to be to the managed database this
time I'm going to select
all from
employee run this
minimize this
now in the table I'm going to get the
data from get employees so just use get
employees data and now we're going to
you guessed it download this table go
back here refresh this page and then I'm
just going to drag in that table like so
and once again I'm just going to hit
next scroll down hit next and let's call
this and flow yes
and generate the API
once again now let's copy this and now
we're going to have to edit all the data
in table five right here so let's just
change this out to be
employees and once again for here
employees
employees
employees
employees
and employees
okay so that's all done and on the
action well that is fine and we are
getting these selected row
so in fact we might need to change this
to be
one end so let's go ahead and perhaps
replace that
just like so and then get rid of
this
and great so now let's test it out let's
select this row right here let's copy
this and paste it in and wonderful that
seems to work we might have to change it
for this API as I think we just use the
other one so let's just see check if it
works select the row copy this
place it in okay that does not work we
clearly use the wrong API let's see if
we can
get back our other one if I just go back
that has not seemed to work so I'm just
going to remake this API
hit next
hit next again
call this customers generate the API
copy this API and then in here on table
three on the action just paste the whole
thing like so and delete the customers
pot okay so great so now let's select a
row copy it paste it in
and that now works we are getting all
the customers
great
so there you go one last thing we're
going to do and that is actually use
this API so this one right here on the
employees
so once again it's just this one and
then we're gonna get
this
make a new query so new resource query
I'm going to call this get employees
from rest API
this is going to be to a rest query
we're going to paste that in and just
put in employees
okay I'm safe and run
great so that brings back our data and
in here I'm just gonna use get
employees data
wonderful
okay so you get that just now I'm not
going to carry on and do all of them but
we have our three right here for the
developer portal and I'm happy with that
okay and that's it I hope you've learned
a lot in this tutorial and I really hope
you've gained some skills and knowledge
in building internal tools using low
code Solutions